I think it's great to have that support
and that love around you because you
need that you know this isn't an easy
easy job so it's good to have
that to to free you up from it every now
and then
that love and support Zendaya's talking
about yeah she's referring to her
boyfriend Tom Holland I think Zendaya
just sounds like the couple met when
they were cast in 2017 Spider-Man
homecoming
you guys are losers and fans speculated
for years that their on-screen chemistry
was also happening off screen you know I
love that you were so open about those
pesky dating rumors where Tom Holland in
this issue why was it important to be
like hey guys come on this like my best
friend well because I mean it happens
all the time and of course you know we
we expected it I mean it's it's um it
comes with the territory it comes with
the job so it's all good after a string
of sightings out together Tom officially
confirmed the news to GQ in November
2021 in a sort of roundabout way quote
one of the downsides of our Fame is that
privacy isn't really in our control
anymore and a moment that you think is
between two people that love each other
very much is now a moment that is shared
with the entire world that moment Tom's
talking about went down in July 2021
when picks of the two kissing in a car
got leaked that's pictures of you and
Tom and people were so excited because
they're like Spider-Man MJ it's real
like it was like the world was rooting
for this moment well I'm I'm excited for
the film to come out I can't wait for
everybody this
Spider-Man when it does come out and you
know we we all work so hard we're all so
you know we're all so close from that
and
um yeah I mean I I I'm excited I just
thought it was cool because people were
actually rooting they were you know look
the internet can be a cynical place and
it was overall Joy it seemed when those
pictures came well thank you but over
time the couple got more comfortable
showing off their love shortly after Tom
confirmed their relationship the two got
cozy at an event in Paris let's also not
forget about the lovebirds posting sweet
birthday tributes first Tom posted about
Z's special day last year writing a
personal note to her on his Instagram my
MJ had the happiest of birthdays give me
a call when you're up yeah I was it was
sweet I guess I don't know
um
um yeah no I um I appreciated you know
the love that I got from my loved ones
and then also from you know the world it
was I felt incredibly loved and grateful
for for all of that so you know I have
no complaints it was a great birthday
then this year Z returned the love
writing quote happiest of birthdays to
the one who makes me the happiest fast
forward to the 2022 Emmys and Zendaya
becoming a repeat winner taking home the
trophy again for lead actress in a drama
series for her work as Rue on euphoria
I just really missed you
I really miss you too
inner sweet she thanked all her loved
ones you didn't shout out to Tom was
that not no no no no he's part of my
loved ones see there you go so whether
they're fighting crime on screen now
that everybody knows you don't really
have to hide or lie to people or
stealing a spidey smooch in real life
these two make love look good
foreign